in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Redmond
and Angeles injili I have no idea
Angela's gonna mess it up welcome guys
where are you from from Salt Lake City
Utah fine welcome to Nashville good to
have you and so you're here to do your
debt free [ __ ] yes we are how much have
you paid off about 50 50 grand Wow good
for you and how long did that take 32
months way to go and range of income
during that time when I started it was
about 36 grand and later on we ended
around 50 grand a year very good very
good very cool what kind of debt was the
fifty thousand cars school loans credit
card business everything very cool very
cool
well congratulations making us so what
happened 32 months ago they started this
journey um actually a year before my
aunt told me about you and I thought it
was a get-rich-quick scheme so I did I
was like I blew her off
and then someone came to our house to
sell us some life insurance and she said
okay you need to get all your debt and
we gathered all our debt I'd never done
this and that's when I saw there was 36
grand so we actually had 36 but today we
paid off 50 grand Wow
so yeah that's where it all started Wow
okay
so what may how'd you guys get connected
to us then you came back around yeah
well she actually when she came to saw
the life insurance she told us about you
she said do you hear about Dave Ramsey
snowball there and I go yeah I know Dave
Ramsey I don't know it's not snowball
effect she told us about the snowball
effect I was like that sounds really
cool and so we jumped on it and when we
jumped on it we went to my aunt's house
the same amount that told us about you
my grandma had a stroke and so she said
she has a basement apartment she said
you want to move here and you can take
care of Rama and I'll you know give you
a less rent and you can get out of debt
faster so he helped us and she's
listening right now so oh that's awesome
yeah very cool very cool so uh so for 32
months you've been taking care of her
and you guys got your costs way down and
got on a written budget I guess I mean
what was this
secret to getting out of debt for you
all learn how to cook I love it so are
you now a good cook three years later my
husband I try we just elevated the same
three meals but neither could we go to
weddings and bridal showers and all
those other functions even people you
don't know yeah just crash the weddings
I love it you guys are fun this is great
very very well done and the kids are
with you yes and their ages and names
are what um Rihanna is seven mm-hmm
brain is six and then we have a daughter
one year old her name is Riya oh yes
okay very cool very cool well
congratulations you guys very proud of
you we have a signed copy of Chris
Hogan's book number one bestseller
retire inspired thank you so that now
you go from no debt to now building
wealth big-time and living like no one
else so later you can live and give like
no one else and sorry can I say one more
thing sure my um heavy did you I see the
Olympics with a guy without a shirt
that's where we're from were from Tonga
okay so he put us on the map but I just
want to say this is for all the
punishing people the Tongans are the
most giving people you will ever meet
and I loved your I'm saying to give like
no one else um that's one of the things
I jumped on and now we can give and not
stress out anymore very cool so I want
to give a shout out to all the pawn
agents you can do this I love it good
for you way to go alright Redmond and
Angela's of Salt Lake City count it down
fifty thousand dollars paid off in 32
months count it down let's hear a debt
free scream one two three
love it love it love it very well done
you guys
very very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
company